riot games and bungie have joined forces
to file
a massive joint lawsuit against a major
cheat distributor
specifically to protect both valorant
and destiny 2
from hackers gator cheats offers a
variety of cheats
in a bunch of games but most shocking is
its valorant offerings
which apparently can beat even riot's
precious vanguard anti-chief
all right boys and girls we're on our
way to 2 million subscribers
if you're into these videos if you like
the score's content scroll down
hit that subscribe button and turn on
notifications so you never miss a video
alright so like i said off the top riot
games and bungie
they've teamed up to file a lawsuit
against a known cheat distributor
called gator cheats specifically it
alleges that cameron santos who works
for the company among others
has sold quote a portfolio of malicious
cheats and hacks
this portfolio includes selling cheats
on gator cheats
but doesn't stop there the lawsuit
suggests that santos and his team
also sell cheats via email discord
telegram and it says that they may work
for other websites as well
riot games and bungie have teamed up
because gator cheats prominently sells
cheats for destiny 2
a bungee product and valard riot's
newest bay
and tactical shooter esport the lawsuit
also suggests that they're known to sell
cheats in other games as well
now this all started last year on
november 11th when
bungie served a cease and desist letter
to santos
targeting the cheats he was selling for
destiny 2. then according to the lawsuit
three days later on november 14th santos
acknowledged the cease-assist letter and
said that he would take down his destiny
tucci's the lawsuit also suggests that
after doing so
he also told his existing customers who
were
already paying for destiny 2 cheats that
he would keep up his service
and then four days later on november
18th the destiny 2 cheats were removed
from gator cheats home page
but according to the lawsuit they were
allegedly still being sold
in a private this led to bungie teaming
up with riot
and filing a lawsuit on january 8th
seeking what could be
tens if not hundreds of thousands of
dollars in damages and fees
quote riot and bungie are the owners and
publishers of two of the most popular
online multiplayer video games in the
world
by this lawsuit plaintiff seek to put a
stop to the unlawful
for-profit sale and distribution of
malicious software products
designed to enable members of the public
to gain unfair competitive advantages
in the games and thereby to impair and
destroy plaintiffs games
plaintiff's overall business and the
experience of plaintiff's player
community
end quote now before i dive a little
deeper into this lawsuit
let me explain to you what this cheat
company actually offers
gator cheats basically offers a
subscription service to cheat at video
games
it's not unlike many of the other
cheating companies
we've talked about on this very show for
valerian you pay ninety dollars for a
one month subscription
250 dollars for a three month
subscription and 500
for a lifetime subscription for destiny
2 they offer a 100
option for 3 months and a 200 option
for a lifetime membership the lawsuit
describes a number of different hacks
the company provides
including pov changes aim locks and the
ability to see players positions
and their stats anywhere on the map
their offering specifically includes a
cheat they call
gatorant which is extremely original
that targets valkyrie now i did a video
last year when ballarant
first dropped about its proprietary
anti-cheat called
vanguard and how it injects itself into
the kernel level
of your computer for maximum scumbag
catching capabilities so if you like
esports you probably
hate cheaters it's just that simple so
when riot unveiled valorant they did so
with the promise of stopping hackers
right in their tracks but it comes at a
cost an intrusive piece of software
called vanguard
that runs on your computer constantly i
even spoke to a couple experts who told
me that if you
really want to catch cheaters you need
intrusive anti-cheats
the engine that the game is running on
is unreal engine 4
and there's a source codes for that
there's a lot of things so you can make
cheats really easy on valorent
because of its engine the anti-cheat is
where
it says nah you're not you're not
getting in this game it's it just throws
you out basically so you need to find a
way to bypass
that anti-cheat in order to uh get your
cheat in there
and also you also have to maintain
it undetected and that is going to be
really hard
with this anti-cheat well this product
called
gatorant is specifically designed to
circumvent vanguard
and offer you undetected a-blocks
so much for the best anti-cheat out
there not only that but the lawsuit also
suggests that gatorade comes with what's
basically an id scrambler
which allows people with permaband
accounts to
still play so here we are seven months
after one of the most sophisticated
anti-cheats out there was announced
and everybody was worried that riot
games and 10 cent was going to be spying
on them
only to hear that riot is now suing a
company
who has found a way to make vanguard
basically useless
the lawsuit suggests that gatorant alone
has been downloaded
and used in the game thousands of times
so that's where we're at cheater sells
cheats bungie sends them a cease and
desist
they don't seem to cease and desist
anything and now ryan and bungie
have sued their asses but what for
obviously
cheating sucks but what i always come
back to time and time again with these
stories
is what is actually illegal about what's
being done
well here's what the lawsuit says it
accuses santos of
three specific legal violations the
first
is trafficking in circumvention devices
which basically means
selling a product that's sole purpose is
to bypass the game's anti-cheat
and their audio visual features the
second is intentional interference with
contractual relations
which means that these cheats violate
the user agreement
that has to be accepted when you install
one of these games
and selling something that intentionally
interferes with that contractual
relationship is illegal
the last one is unfair competition this
suggests that the business of selling
cheats
damages the game devs and quote unjustly
enriches
the self with all this in mind the
lawsuit asks for the immediate shutdown
of gator cheats
and santos's operation it asks for them
to pay damages
and lawyer fees and also asks for them
to provide riot and bungie
the cheats that they have right away
between the cost of the legal fees and
the suggested
thousands of copies of these cheats that
have already been sold
we're talking tens if not hundreds of
thousands of dollars
that gator sheets would have to pay off
and if you look at their website
everything has been removed from gator
cheats
at least for now but from my perspective
this is all a little bittersweet on the
one hand
this is a good thing massive developers
putting their metaphorical foot down
and keeping our rank games aimbot free
riot even alluded to how aggressive
they're trying to be against cheaters
when they spoke to polygon
about this lawsuit quote cheating
undermines a game's competitive
integrity and erodes community trust
riot is wholly committed to upholding
these values for its players
so when we become aware of a cheat maker
you bet we're going to go after them
end quote that said as i alluded to
earlier
it really hasn't been that long that we
thought that the kernel level
access of something like vanguard would
finally be enough
to keep cheaters out of a competitive
game like valerie the fact is
from rainbow six to cs go to valor into
warzone
cheaters are worse than ever and no
matter how many gigantic lawsuits
happen it doesn't seem like that's going
to change anytime soon
to cease and desist must have is this
real
i hate gum souls man the only shoes i'm
like kind of retired from buying shoes
despite this like [ __ ] obviously
massive collection that i have
um the only i just keep buying new
balance bet dad shoes i don't really
like buying anything else anymore
it's [ __ ] over i'm retired